I
Haven't had Japanese McDonald's before but I'm very interested in what they have we actually came here during soccer season
And it happens that McDonald's is actually selling limited Edition soccer S stuff
This is the toughest aku soccer a McFLurry. I can't quite tell what's inside this McFlurry, but it's Gonna taste like flowers
It's actually pretty good. It's not too sweet it tastes like cereal, Sort of cherry Flavor
It's like if you took all the red fruity pebbles and put them into ice cream
Those giga bacon to E tama what does teddy time? I mean just teriyaki an egg. Oh
I see [okay]
Fisher
Hmm here's Evan please they're like a lot of flavor tapping in my mouth
You should put eggs more often burgers Japan really knows how to do their eggs usually a light bacon
Crispy like I want my baking to be like oily and like you can literally snap it in half don't get me wrong he doesn't
taste Bad
This is the meadow and shake. I know that there's a lot of Japanese flavored candies and Suffice Melon flavors
it's actually pretty decent and
It has a slight came to it. I would describe this as a less citrusy
Creamsicle I wouldn't order it every time I come to McDonalds
I'm usually not a big fan of melon flavor, but in this shape form I'm pretty okay with it
this is the Shaka Shaka chicken Chuck amin sheikh and basically what you do is important like Powder inside the chicken bag and
Shake it
She throws a little strong. This is like a cheese and meat for me
It's basically like a big piece of cheetos, but with chicken hidden shaking up your food is fun, though
We should have more of that in the station [all] [right], so this is the be feeding in English
It's supposed to be the trim filet
I'm very excited because I love shrimp the first thing we have four trim sandwich is a po boy
Hmm, I
like fish
It kind of tastes like a fishy chicken. I definitely want this to be in the space. This is so good
I think there's something wrong with your taste buds shop
This is the sucker Evie. She'll fries you pour it into the fries
It smells a lot like shrimp chips, and I love shrimp chips. Why was it?
That's chases a little bit too strong in comparison to shrimp Chips you buy into it, and you think like oh
It's a little salty, but then the spice like rises in your throat I
Thought that was a roller coaster of emotions only the burgers are good
But I think I'd prefer the sweet stuff definitely try to come during soccer season because it's not just the food
It's also just beautiful here. I think America McDonald's might have to step up their game a little more
I
think mom if you